es como si la pandemia hubiese matado a
tres estadios del maracaná llenos y si
tú sales a la calle parece que no pasa
nada en la mayoría de las ciudades del
río de janeiro vemos bares llenos las
playas llenas y un negacionismo entre
una población que está ya muy cansada de
esta pandemia también hay que decir que
esta cifra es muy grave y muy dramática
brasil es el país con más muertos en
términos absolutos sólo por detrás de
los eeuu pero no es el país que tiene
más muertos con relación a los 100.000
habitantes países como portugal italia
gran bretaña tienen unas tasas de
mortalidad mucho más altas
eso sí brasil está entre los 30 países
con más muertos por causa de este virus
y también hay que decir que la pandemia
hasta ahora ha matado a más personas que
todas las personas que fueron muertas
por homicidio el año pasado aún así
repito en la calle se vive una situación
de casi normalidad
valeria brevemente mientras que algunas
naciones del continente apenas inician
las inoculaciones brasilia lleva más de
un mes de campaña como se ve el panorama
de la vacunación en el país
la vacunación arranca arrancado tarde y
procede a trompicones de momento sean
vacunados unos 6,1 millones de
brasileños que equivalen a casi el 3 por
ciento de la población pero por ejemplo
en la semana pasada el río de janeiro
salvador de bahía y otras ciudades
tuvieron que interrumpir por falta de
dosis el proceso de vacunación hoy río
de janeiro ha reanudado el ayuntamiento
ha recibido nuevas dosis pero hay una
serie de problemas ayer supimos que
manaos una de las ciudades más afectadas
del país no recibió las 76.000 dosis que
esperaba por un error del ministerio de
salud fue un gran escándalo hay que
recordar que emanaban se está viviendo
una segunda ola muy fuerte ya se ha
muerto más personas en dos meses que en
todo el año pasado y se espera que el
próximo mes por causa de la mutación del
virus pueda ser aún más grave se habla
incluso de una pandemia dentro de la
pandemia san paolo tiene ya el récord
máximo de hospitalizaciones y ha
introducido un pequeño lockdown nocturno
que la situación es preocupante valeria
pues muchas gracias por todos estos
detalles estamos muy pendientes de lo
que ocurra en brasil